[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine golf
les capitaines de la ryder cup 2018
thomas bjorn et fleury qui était ce
lundi matin au golf national de
saint-quentin divine pour taper quelques
balles sur le parcours de l'albatros à
un peu moins d'un an du début de la
troisième plus grande compétition
sportive planétaire les détails dans ce
magazine course à pied la cinquième
édition de la bible troisième s'est
tenue ce dimanche dans la commune de
villepreux quatre courses étaient au
programme dont un 10 km l'événement
réunit plus de 600 participants nous y
reviendrons dans quelques instants
enfin il y avait du football ce week-end
le club de trappes jouer à son cinquième
match de la saison contre le leader
ozoir le match s'est soldé par un
récital des trappistes qui l'ont emporté
4 à 0 sur leur pelouse avec quatre buts
inscrits en première période
le résumé est à suivre on commence tout
de suite ce magazine par l'actualité
sportive de la semaine
[Musique]
un peu moins d'un an de la ryder cup en
france son golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les capitaines
thomass viande pour l'europe et jim fric
pour les états unis dès ce lundi matin
sur le site
ils sont venus s'affronter dans un match
amical pour lancer les festivités du one
year to go l'événement qui enclenche la
dernière ligne droite de l'organisation
de la ryder cup 2018 les capitaines ont
également tapé quelques balles sur le
practice devant plus de 1000 enfants
on écoute les réactions les capitaines
viennent souvent pour visiter le
parcours mais il n'y a jamais vrai il
n'ya qu'une seule visite officielle
c'est celle qui se fait un nom avant
donc elle est très importante
c'est un parcours de golf fantastique et
d'être le capitaine de cette ryder cup
est vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants
je suis très excité à l'idée de vivre
cette ryder cup à paris nous savons que
c'est un grand événement et voir combien
ça peut rapporter
non seulement pendant les jours de
compétition maison dehors c'est génial
et voir les enfants enthousiastes c'est
une bonne chose
demain direction paris pour les deux
capitaines ils taperont quelques balles
du haut de la tour eiffel du jamais vu
depuis 1977 et la légende américaine du
golfe arnold palmer qui répondront juste
après aux différentes questions de la
presse sur l'événement enfin la visite
se terminera par un dîner de gala au
château de versailles
nous allons continuer à parler de la
ryder cup 2018 avec le chef de projet à
ryder cup à saint quentin en yvelines et
xavier küssnacht sz merci de nous avoir
rejoints pour parler de ce one year to
go qui se déroule en ce moment en région
parisienne et notamment dans les
yvelines quand on a pu le voir sur les
images précédentes
xavier cet événement lance-t-il la
dernière ligne droite avant la ryder cup
absolument michael la ryder cup qui a
lieu dans moins d'un an à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc cette
opération one year to go qui vraiment
qui annonce à tout le monde que ce soit
aussi bien aux saint quentinois comme
monde entier qui agace plus que moins
d'un an à voir l'accueil de ce grand
évènement donc c'est vrai que c'est
l'événement phare comme le disait
monsieur griso dans le reportage c'est
l'événement qui indique qui reste plus
que quelques mois avant l'accueil de ce
grand événement et c'est important de
mettre en place cette grande opération
de communication sur la tour eiffel au
château de versailles ou golf national
pour faire connaître cette ryder cup
l'escale a encore besoin
la faire connaître cette je pense car
nourrir sa travailleurs quand il y en a
besoin
ne serait-ce qu'en france puisque c'est
vrai que c'est un sport qui est
mondialement connu et mondialement
plébiscité mais beaucoup plus dans les
pays anglo saxons on le voit c'est
l'équivalent du football un états unis
ou en angleterre
chez nous c'est vrai que c'est un sport
encore méconnu ou encore un peu fermes
et il a cette image élitiste et le fait
de faire ce genre d'opération avec des
enfants les scolaires et même l'ouvrir
au grand public ça montre que c'est un
sport est en tout cas un événement qui
est accessible à tout le monde et c'est
l'un des enjeux c'est justement de cette
opération manière tout finalement on
communique sur paris même plus plus que
sur 50 ans et demi dont on communique
sur paris le château de versailles le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça forcément
peut pas on peut pas faire événement
global finalement c'est un peu comme les
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 tout
âge fait ça c'est vrai que la ryder cup
a lieu en france
premièrement elle a lu à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est une
fierté c'est une c'est une réalité il ya
lieu aussi beaucoup en france et les
gens qui vont venir du monde entier pour
la vivre ont également profité pour
visiter notre pays visité la capitale
on espère aussi bien sûr visiter le
territoire saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que tout est prêt à un an de la
ryder cup
en tout cas on fait tout pour que tout
soit prêt dans un peu moins d'un an
côté saint quentin en yvelines c'est
vrai que vous avez pu le voir lors de
golf expérience il ya la semaine
dernière qu'on amis et qu'on met en
place un grand plan d'action pour aller
à la rencontre justement les saint
quentinois de leur parlais ryder cup on
a vraiment tout un plan d'actions
promotionnelles qui a été mis en place
et en terme de logistique bien
évidemment il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de boulot mais on y travaille
on est vraiment soutien nous 50 ans une
vigne de l'organisateur sur ces
problématiques de logistique et de
transport et voilà je vous rassure on
sera prêt dans moins d'un an
on a l'impression qu'à 50 ans on y vient
on a un petit peu accéléré vraiment le
mouvement ryder cup
vous parliez de la golf expérience est
également des événements sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
avec l'urss pourquoi avoir décidé
d'accélérer à un an de
parce que justement on s'en rapproche
c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps qu'on
en parle plus ou moins à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines faut savoir
que saint quentin en yvelines et quand
même partenaire de la fédération
française de golf dans la candidature la
ryder cup depuis 2009
donc les agents
saint-quentin-en-yvelines travaille
vraiment depuis plus de nombreuses
années mais la voilà on a moins d'un an
donc on a besoin justement de tout
accéléré et de dire aux saint quentinois
que l'événement va avoir lieu
quelles vont être les conséquences qui
va forcément avoir des conséquences
logistiques sur l'accueil d'un tel
événement mais surtout d'aller à la
rencontre des saint quentinois pour leur
part les riders leur faire découvrir
aussi bien l'événement qu'est la ryder
cup mais aussi leur faire découvrir le
golf et leur montrer que c'est vraiment
un sport qui est accessible à tous
vous avez senti sur le terrain vous à
saint quentin en yvelines que les
spectateurs enfin les gens étaient
concernés par cette ryder cup 2 les
jointures spectateurs progrès de plus en
plus évidemment on voit beaucoup de gens
à venir nous poser des questions
s'intéresser à l'événement que ce soit
le côté sportif pour savoir en quoi ça
consiste mais même sur le fait de savoir
s'il y aura des animations qui seront
prévues pour les saint quentinois
est-ce qu évidemment la ryder cup c'est
une coupe du monde c'est la coupe du
monde de golf donc tout le monde n'aura
pas accès aux gosses nationale pendant
la ryder cup et c'est pour ça que 50 ans
élise mettre en place beaucoup
d'animations pour justement c'est à dire
quel type d'animation alors déjà vous
êtes peut-être au courant qu'on a un
village ryder cup qui va ce qui va
vraiment évolué pendant un an dans
toutes les communes de l'agglomération
pour aller la rencontre justement des
saint quentinois et par les golfs par
les ryder cup
on va voir aussi nous beaucoup
d'événements sportifs la ryder cup des
scolaires la riderz cup des étudiants
pardon la ryder cup des saint quentinois
des entreprises pour vraiment mon
l'ouvrir à tout le monde et donner la
possibilité à tout le monde sur
territoire de jouer on aura un golf
expérience 2 également au mois de juin
on ira justement à trois mois de
l'accueil de l'événement sur le
territoire parlait encore aux saint
quentinois et leur fait découvrir le
golf de manière un peu plus urbaine et
enfin évidemment pendant la ryder cup on
aura notre fan zone ryder cup qui sera
le seul lieu gratuit pour pouvoir soit
7,25 au vélodrome nationale
cela voilà donc du 28 au 30 septembre
pendant les trois jours de compétition
et ce sera vraiment le seul lieu pour
pouvoir suivre la compétition en direct
et gratuitement sur tout avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'animations ouvert aussi bien
aux saint quentinois quand même aux
franciliens le but c'est vraiment de
rassembler tout le monde pour vivre cet
événement extraordinaire alors sur le
plan sportif
aucun français n'est pour l'instant
assuré de participer à cette ryder cup
en france comme nous l'a confié le
capitaine de la team europe
thomas bjorn on écoute mon travail c'est
de choisir les meilleurs joueurs aux
européens pour ces matches il reste
beaucoup de temps pour le faire et
joueurs français savent que pour être
dans l'équipe
ils doivent montrer qu'ils sont assez
bon et qu'il joue assez bien
qu'est ce que vous pensez à examiner ses
nièces de la réponse de thomas bjorn
cette précision des français dans
l'équipe et il a tout à fait raison
c'est vrai que pour les français même
pour nous ça sera une fierté et même la
cerise sur le gâteau d'avoir des joueurs
français participant à la ryder cup ce
déjà été le cas par le passé mais là
c'est chez nous c'est à saint quentin en
yvelines on a besoin de joueurs français
pour justement toujours créer ce
sentiment de fierté finalement
d'accueillir un événement un mondial
c'est vrai que ce serait quand même
l'avouer la cerise sur le gâteau si on
avait un joueur français donc on espère
que leurs performances vont être très
bonne sur les mois à venir pour qu'on
ait au moins un joueur français dans
cette équipe et ruelles et au niveau de
la communication
c'est mieux d'avoir un français c'est
toujours mieux puisque nous justement
véhicule beaucoup en terme de
communication sur justement la fierté
d'accueillir un tel événement et la
fierté de faire partie d'une terre
d'accueil de grands événements sportifs
internationaux donc le fait d'avoir un
français on aurait quand même des axes
de communication assez naturel pour
jouer sur ce sentiment de fierté
en ce moment on parle beaucoup de victor
dubuisson qui joue mieux sur le tour
européen depuis quelques semaines il a
d'ailleurs réalisé une très belle
troisième place à john eales links
championship
voilà est-ce que victor dubuisson serait
la tête d'affiche parfaite
il est connu du grand public français il
a des bons résultats
il est connu en effet comme vous le
dites il a des bons résultats il a déjà
gagné la ryder cup faut le souligner
donc ça qu'il est pour apporter cette
expérience aussi alors 2014 en 2014 tout
à fait donc c'est vrai que ce serait oui
ce serait une belle tête d'affiché mais
voilà il ya
joueur également qu' français qui sont
très prometteurs qui font une bonne
saison on espère qu'ils vont faire une
meilleure saison mais voilà les vielles
compagnie ce sont des joueurs qui
potentiellement pourrait également faire
partie de l'équipe européenne et qui
pourrait séduire thomas bjorn
merci à vous que j'ai vécu soutenir si
on vous souhaite beaucoup de courage
pour préparer au mieux cette ryder cup à
saint quentin en yvelines
on imagine que vous n'avez pas forcément
beaucoup dormir dans l'année qui vient
pour voir réparer au mieux cette
compétition pas prévu de prendre
beaucoup de vacances mais en tout cas on
est vraiment fiers de proposer autant de
choses aux saint quentinois j'aimerais
du coup conclure avec une dernière choir
d'allemands très rapidement j'invite
tous les saint quentinois se rendre sur
le site entrons dans la légende point fr
qui donnera vraiment beaucoup
d'informations sur l'accueil de la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines
merci xavier que ce nerf après une large
page golf un mot de course à pied la
cinquième édition de la ville prose yen
s'est tenue ce dimanche 15 octobre dans
la commune de villepreux 630 adultes et
enfants ont pu participer à des courses
de 1 km 2 km 5 km ou encore l'épreuve
reine de cette journée le 10 km un
reportage de nicolas d'henri une matinée
sportive entre frère et soeur mélanie et
julien se sont lancé un challenge
participer à une course de 10 km le
plaisir de courir pour cette fratrie
originaire de villepreux wagnon sera
entraîné un petit peu mais franchement
une fois par semaine à peu près voilà on
fait pas partie d'un club donc c'est
plus de loisirs
j'ai trouvé une source de motivation
aussi avec ma soeur donc on a déjà couru
plusieurs fois ensemble c'est vraiment
très sympa mélanie et julien font partie
des 200 aux coureurs qui ont pris le
départ du 10 km une boucle de 5 km à
parcourir deux fois à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de la ville
c'est un mix de durban 1 et 2
on va dire deux trails donc on a on a
des parcours sur terre donc qu'on tourne
essentiellement ville preuve avec un
premier tour réalisé en 18 minutes 42
adrien grappille remporte cette course à
la maison en 38 minutes 30 pour le vivre
provient cette cinquième participation
aura été la bonne il devance de 30
secondes
emmanuel prix bas c'est mon premier
podium et donc dans ma ville ça fait
vraiment super plaisir je connais c'est
à peu près le parcours et je savais où
faire la différence
de leur côté mélanie et julien ont
terminé la course en une heure et six
minutes auront pas s'arrêter là pour
motiver parce que ces tests éprouvant
surtout la deuxième le deuxième tour la
l2 côte là qui nous ont bien bien
classés l'objectif c'était qu'on arrive
en même temps à la course à l'arrivée
donc voilà on sait attendu chacun a
pendant un trajet pour l'édition 2018 de
la ville proviennent les organisateurs
réfléchissent à une nouvelle course de
15 km et peut-être un jour proposer un
semi marathon
nous allons maintenant parler de
football et de la 5e journée du
championnat de r4 l'équipe seniors de
l'étoile sportive de trappes a réalisé
une très belle performance sur son
terrain en infligeant un cinglant 4 à 0
leader de la division le fc ozoir les
quatre buts ont été inscrits avant à la
mi-temps le résumé du match le montage
est signée romain aarhus fini
c'était le choc de cette 5e journée du
championnat r4 trappe en rouge 6e avant
la rencontre se met sur sa pelouse ozoir
le leader invaincu qui n'avait encaissé
que deux buts cette saison après
seulement 26 minutes de jeu les
trappistes ont déjà fait sauter le
verrou de la défense adverse pour mener
3 0
et puis 4 à 0 avant la mi temps avec ce
but du milieu de terrain kaka ou diallo
j'ai l'opportunité de pouvoir faire un
relais avec mon attaquant qui me donne
et dans ce cas là bas je vais je finisse
le seul face au gardien
c'est pas évident j'ai les biens prises
tant mieux c'est rentré je pense qu'avec
un contrôle sera était plus compliqué là
tout de suite en première intention bien
tant mieux pour l'équipe
malgré quelques offensives d'ozoir en
seconde période le score n'évoluera plus
4 à 0 au coup de sifflet final on peut
pas s'attendre à un score aussi
important après on a fait un très bon
début de match ce qui nous a permis
aussi de d'enchaîner peut-être que aussi
leurs erreurs et ils les ont payées
aussi cash
tant mieux pour nous parce qu'on a aussi
été efficace c'est ce qui nous a manqué
tu es derniers matches et on est capable
de faire ce genre de choses là
donc aujourd'hui on tant mieux on en a
mis 4 si on pouvait remettre 5 6 c'était
notre jour donc tant mieux avec cette
victoire trappe se retrouve à la
deuxième place du classement devant son
adversaire du jour
on est dans la bonne partie maintenant
c'est à n'y trouver cette constance qui
va nous permettre d'enchaîner les
victoires
si possible ou du moins d'enchaîner les
bons résultats on est capable de le
faire
la attrape on sait que le sait le
prochain match le plus compliqué donc on
va essayer de bien travailler pour le
prochain match et a ramené le meilleur
résultat possible
prochain match pour l'étoile sportive de
trappes le dimanche 22 octobre sur la
pelouse de maisons alfort l'avant
dernier du classement
on continue par un résultat de football
mais cette fois ci dans le championnat
de division 1 de district maurepas reste
leader à l'issue de cette 5e journée
les norvégiens se sont imposés 2 buts à
1 sur leur terrain au stade du bout des
clos contre lui et ce le pecq
une victoire qui leur permet d'afficher
un bilan de quatre victoires et un nul
depuis le début de la saison et d'avoir
13 points en cinq rencontres disputées
prochain match dimanche prochain sur le
terrain d'hardricourt une équipe englués
à l'avant dernière place du championnat
en basket victoire importante pour le
les féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles l'équipe dans le bas
du classement de nationale 2 avant la
rencontre s'est imposé sur son parquet
contre furdenheim
ce samedi soir le score 68 à 62
pour lécher les hyènes un résultat qui
leur permet de remonter et d'occuper la
9e place du championnat sur 12 équipes
engagées avec un bilan à l'équilibré de
deux victoires et deux défaites en
quatre matches prochaine rencontre pour
lui l cv 78 samedi soir prochain sur le
parquet de saint-amand et nos choix du
rugby à présent d'ailleurs cette page
résultat quatre matches et quatre
défaites pour plaisir dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
wa promu cette saison dans cette
division n'ont jamais pu développer leur
jeu sur le terrain de l'heureux ce
dimanche 15 octobre
ils se sont logiquement inclinés 42 à 12
avec cette défaite le prc restent avant
derniers de la division avec zéro point
aux caisses au classement et une
différence de point de moins 120 contre
moins 129 pour le dernier domont enjoué
également ce week-end sur l'état de
division honneur le sky rugby a concédé
sa deuxième défaite de la saison sur son
terrain contre la nuit à l'occasion de
la 3e journée du championnat
le score est serré 17 à 11 en faveur des
joueurs de la seine-et-marne après cette
contre-performance le sky rugby se
retrouve à la sixième place de la poule
et devra se reprendre dimanche prochain
contre clichy pour espérer ne pas
plonger dans la zone de relégation
la rencontre aura lieu à 15 heures
toujours sur leur pelouse du stade du
bout des clous on ouvre après à présent
une page en balles dans ce set 8 sport
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à l'équipe seniors du club de plaisir
après avoir raté la montée pendant à 7
ans les plaisirs oies sont enfin montés
cette saison dans le championnat de
nationale 3 pour l'instant le promu
affiche un bilan de 11 victoires en
trois matches pour nous parler de ce
début de saison nous recevons sur ce
plateau le coach victor guerrier bonsoir
le capitaine benjamin modeste et arnaud
chastre qui vient de rejoindre le club
bonsoir messieurs alors comment jugez
vous ce début de saison
victor je disais une victoire en trois
matchs avec la clé une sixième place
on savait qu'en tant que promu on allait
avoir un calendrier à l'inversé c'est à
dire qu'on allait jouer les premiers sur
les premiers matches donc on s'attendait
à un début de saison assez difficile
n'était content de tir et massy
palaiseau sur le premier match une
équipe jeune c'est une équipe réserve de
première division
donc on sait qu'ils sont plus de temps
pour se mettre en place donc c'était une
bonne chose de les tirer au premier
match et ça a été plutôt positive que
c'est notre seule victoire à ce jour les
deux autres matches sont des matches
contre des équipes solides certainement
plus physiques que nous avec avec de
l'expérience donc voilà les résultats
restent positifs en tout cas l'état
d'esprit est au rendez vous donc
j'espère que ça promet de belles choses
j'avais un vous qui avez vécu de
nombreuses saisons à à plaisir vous êtes
un petit peu l'ancien de cette équipe
vous attendiez un niveau si élevé cette
année en nationale 3 je pense qu'on est
tombé sur une des poules les plus
costauds faut savoir sur les deux
équipes il ya trois équipes qui ne sont
pas de la région parisienne
donc voilà c'est très physique
ça se joue pendant une heure on peut
voir sur les premiers matches sur nos
deux défaites contre plus tôt et saint
pol sur mer on a on a quand même
l'avantagé sur sur le jeu pendant 15
minutes
derrière on a un trou de 10 minutes et
on n'arrive pas à refaire le score ce
qu'on arrivait à faire en prennent note
on pouvait se permettre d'avoir dix
quinze minutes de trou parce qu'on avait
la capacité de revenir
on voit qu'au niveau n3 c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué il faut être constant
pendant une heure l'éditeur vous avez
gardé la même philosophie de jeu par
rapport à la saison dernière où vous
avez adapté votre équipe par rapport au
type reste globalement la même et avec
avec des valeurs et des qualités qui
induisent un certain projet de jeu donc
aujourd'hui notre projet de jeu n'a pas
fondamentalement changé donc on reprend
là où s'était arrêté l'année passée on
essaye de ramener petit à petit de
nouvelles chaussures projet de jeu
offensif notamment
mais sinon on regarde la même
philosophie de jeu vous étiez très
offensif la saison dernière cette année
c'est la même chose alors on essaye
après on est un peu plus de difficulté à
marquer des buts que des saisons passées
à ce que l'on récupère moins mal
des erreurs de nos adversaires qui sont
plus forts donc on a moins de moins de
buts sur le jeu rapide en attaque placée
on
on a affaire à des défenses plus solide
plus costaud avec le plus de gabarit
donc voila nous falloir un peu de temps
pour nous adapter mais on reste quand
même sur un total de buts inscrits qui
est quand même assez important
on tourne systématiquement la de 25 buts
donc ça reste quand même un nombre
important de buts mais ou encore de la
progression de ce côté là arnaud vous
êtes le petit nouveau de cette équipe
pourquoi avoir décidé de rejoindre
plaisir c'est une bonne question ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on me demande de
venir jouer à plaisir et pourquoi cette
année parce que l'opportunité s'est
présentée
surtout parce que mes amis ont arrêté de
jouer au handball à voisins et donc j'ai
décidé de sauter le pas pour rejoindre
d'autres personnes que je connais très
bien et avec qui j'ai joué surtout
contre et pendant des tourments l'été
donc je me suis bien amusé pendant dix
ans avec mes amis voisins et maintenant
jouer en national bas ça fait ça fait du
bien et c'est un niveau qui qui fait
plaisir tout simplement le groupe vit
bien mais alors pour moi je pense que je
me suis bien intégré au groupe et puis
d'une manière générale le groupe vivait
plutôt bien avant je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui à une très très bonne
entente au niveau des joueurs aussi bien
dans le jeu que même dans la ville
groupe une fois que les entraînements
sont terminés ou à la fin des matches
moi je crois qu'on a une très bonne mine
group pour nom benjamin vous êtes
actuellement 6e du classement
est ce que finalement c'est votre place
aujourd'hui oui on voulait viser encore
plus haut on sait que sur les quatre
premiers matches de championnat on tape
on tape les quatre plus grosses équipes
de la poule clairement donc on a fait un
bel exploit contre massy mais qui pour
moi n'est pas encore rodé voilà plutôt
saint pol sur mer et
saint gratien qui on va jouer la semaine
prochaine ça restera les grosses écuries
donc je pense que notre championnat
commencera à partir de la stella et je
pense que on doit se fixer comme
objectif un bon top 5
être ambitieux il t'a vous confirmez top
5 ces meules top3 peut-être c'est une
belle perf j'aimerais bien aller tâter
un petit peu clown très honnêtement vous
pensez que vous allez groupe aux mails
magny cours il faut qu' il faut qu'on
soit dans une bonne dynamique là en
effet on a une passe de match assez
compliqué faudra voir quels sont les
pots cassés à l'issue de cette cette
phase là et après on est des
compétiteurs donc j'espère qu'on fera en
tout cas des belles perf contre des
équipes censées être plus forte que nous
merci à tous les trois des de passer sur
ce plateau ou souhaite évidemment bon
courage pour la suite de la saison votre
prochain match ça sera contre l'élite
val d'oise ce samedi à 20h45 au centre
des sports de franconville hameau de
boxe à présent ahmed el moussaoui se
rapproche d'un titre mondial dans la
catégorie des poids welters halle berry
roi de 27 ans a dominé aux points le
mexicain carlos molina ce samedi soir au
zénith de paris dans la soirée baptisée
la conquête
après avoir emmené son adversaire au
tapis d'un crochet du droit au milieu du
deuxième ronde il a dû tout de même
batailler jusqu'au 10e rendre pour
s'adjuger une victoire à l'unanimité des
trois juges
ce résultat ce résultat à lui permet
d'intégrer le top 25 mondial dans sa
catégorie
dans l'autre combat de la soirée la star
française tony yoka originaires de
chanteloup les vignes dans les yvelines
s'est lui aussi imposé ce samedi soir
pour son deuxième combat chez les
professionnels le champion olympique a
dû s'employer pour battre aux points
l'américain joe natale rice 30 ans 126
kg dans un combat en s'y rendent les
trois juges lui ont donné la victoire
tony yoka reste donc invaincu au niveau
de son calendrier il a déjà annoncé
vouloir combattre 5 à 6 fois en 2018
entre la france et les états unis
on prend maintenant la direction de
poissy un invité de marque était présent
dans la commune
mercredi dernier sébastien chabal
l'ancien rugbyman du quinze de france et
l'ancien champion du monde christian
karembeu sont venus inaugurer à côté du
stade léo lagrange une aire de street
work out du sport en plein air l'espace
baptisé sport libre de saint-exupéry en
accès libre permet de faire du sport sur
les agréent d'activité qui tient à coeur
à sébastien chabal
écoute j'aurais envie qu'ils retiennent
que faire du sport ça peut être sympa ça
peut être convivial ça peut être gratuit
ça peut créer du lien et que c'est
toujours des bonbons toujours du plaisir
et que c'est important
voilà star est également présente à
poissy à mercredi dernier dans une
ambiance des grands soirs au stade léo
lagrange le variétés club de france a
réalisé son 2260 10e match caritatif
on pouvait noter à la présence dans ses
rangs de plusieurs champions du monde 98
comme christian karembeu laurent blanc
ou encore l'actuel sexuelle
l'actuel sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france pardon dit deschamps les 2000 à
spectateurs présents également pu voir
le joueur du paris saint germain à ben
arfa le montage est signée à xavier
jaglin soirée de gala à poissy sur la
même pelouse au stade léo lagrange
didier deschamps christian karembeu
laurent blanc ou encore alain giresse
ils ont tous répondu présent à l'appel
du variétés club de france pour ce match
caritatif contre une équipe composée
d'amateurs
enfin pau qui se questionnent la taxant
à la retraite dont 4 au 5 août surtout
que du défunt il était hier au stade de
france sera cool qu'il soit venu les
deux mille supporters présents ont même
pu apercevoir un petit nouveau au sein
du variétés florent malouda finaliste de
la coupe du monde 2006 je sais pas s'il
veut mais c'est vrai quelqu'un que vous
commencez avec le variété de vins dire
que c'est face à un cas comme donc
donc oui après bon il ya tellement de
joueurs que avec la fatigue on va gérer
mais ça va j'ai pas j'ai pas de souci à
ce niveau-là mais l'attraction du soir
se nommer le joueur habitué au banc de
touche au psg à créditer le public d'une
grosse prestation pour son premier match
officiel de la saison
passement de jambes accélérations et
même passe décisive sur le premier but
de la rencontre
j'ai couru je me suis donné quand même
j'ai je fais un peu fatigué mais c'est
normal quand on est sur le terrain il
faut il faut donner ce qu'on a donc
donc voilà je suis très content quelques
minutes après l'ouverture du score
l'équipe geodis adverse égalise le
tableau d'affichage n'évoluera plus
score final un but partout
ce cépage parce que sur l' affaire
n'aurait même a mérité en a beaucoup
d'opportunités à l'infini plus fort que
les petits jeunes qui étaient sur la
peau noah face donc c'est sympa
pas de vainqueur sur la pelouse mais une
grande victoire en dehors du terrain les
bénéfices de la rencontre ont permis de
récolter 15 mille euros en faveur des
associations urbain et plus de vie
soutenu par bernadette chirac présente
ce mercredi au stade de poissy le
variétés club de france devrait revenir
l'année prochaine dans les yvelines pour
assurer une nouvelle fois le show
[Musique]
le fc trappes jouera ce samedi à 20h
contre vernon à domicile au gymnase paul
mallet à l'occasion de la 5e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 les
trappistes doivent absolument l'emporter
pour rebondir au classement après deux
défaites consécutives
vernon semble être l'adversaire idéal
pour se relancer l'équipe a seulement
remporté un match depuis le début de la
saison
et puis il y aura à du tir à l'arc ce
week-end à montigny le bretonneux le
club de la commune organise un concours
sélectif salle pour le championnat de
france
une centaine d'archers est attendu au
gymnase pierre de coubertin de la ville
ce samedi de 9h à 19h et ce dimanche de
9h à 17h30 la remise des récompenses est
quant à elle programmée le dimanche aux
alentours de 16h30
avant de refermer à ce magazine une
photo celle du basketteur français
franck nt lykina drafté en juin dernier
par la franchise des new york knicks et
qui s'affiche déjà entre les buildings
de la grosse pomme son agent l'élan
courtois olivier mazet à négocier avec
une célèbre marque de sport pour
installer une affiche publicitaire d'une
vingtaine d'étagés à proximité de son
futur terrain de jeu le madison square
garden l'ancien strasbourgeois until it
in a devrait jouer à ses premières
minutes sous ses nouvelles couleurs ce
jeudi à oklahoma city lors du premier
match de la saison nba
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]